before Groot was the gentle giant fans
know and love today he was a monster
literally a hundred and twenty five foot
tall rampaging alien monster he stayed
that way for 45 years - until a sudden
and unexpected turn transformed him into
a hero and paved the way for his
membership in the guardians of the
galaxy but during his five decades as a
villain Groot caused quite a few
problems and honestly that didn't really
stop when he became a good guy as one of
Marvel's monsters grew terrified
countless humans as a hero is in danger
of returning to his villainous roots
here are just a few ways Groot has
terrorized the Marvel Universe overlord
of timber it's hard to believe but back
in the early days of Marvel Comics Groot
was there right from the beginning even
before the Fantastic Four and The
Incredible Hulk burst onto the scene in
1960s tales to astonish number 13 Stan
Lee and Jack Kirby published a story
called I challenged Groot the monster
from Planet X in which a tree-like beast
crashes to earth and attempts to kidnap
the population of an entire city hoping
to take his prisoners back to his home
world for nefarious experiments normally
that wouldn't be a problem but
superheroes didn't exist in the Marvel
Universe yet so the village was
officially burned
that's because Groot isn't any normal
alien he calls himself the overlord of
all the timber in the galaxy and gets
stronger by absorbing wood not really
and not only can Groot talk but he
towers above the villages like some kind
of wood Zilla destroying everything in
his path
gert brings the local forests to life
and begins rounding up his human
subjects until of course one lowly
scientist discovers groots only weakness
termites as the insects chomp away at
grits wooden body the creature withers
and dies leaving earth
safe for now Hulk smashed the next time
the monster from Planet X appears is in
the Incredible Hulk annual number five
in which a recurring Marvel villain
named xemnu once the challenge the
not-so-jolly Green Giant now to do so he
resurrects Groot and a handful of other
old Marvel monsters really cool guys
with names like Goom and the
electrifying lip you know winners after
smashing his way through a fifth
dimensional demon named Diablo and a mud
monster called taboo groots branches
nearly choked the life out of the Hulk
during the fight group plants his roots
in the ground making himself impervious
to the Hulk's gamma powered punches grid
even whips out a wave of razor-sharp
thorns which seemed all set to finish
the Hulk off for good but all of these
attacks make Hulk angry and you know how
that goes Hulk blocks groots attacks
with a stone which he proceeds to use to
beat groot into a splintered stump but
that wouldn't be the end of group not by
a long shot
breakout brute is a hard guy to keep
down remember he's grown back from a
twig more than once in the 2005 one-shot
monsters on the prowl readers learned
that at some point in the past the
intergalactic super nerd known as the
collector rounded up all of Marvel's
other classic monsters and locked them
away in an underground prison that's
weird and vaguely sinister but
relatively safe at least until mom and
busts the prison wide open freeing Groot
and the whole monster party the army of
monsters make their way from Canada to
New York where they start stomping
everything inside unfortunately for them
Marvel's good monsters the thing the
Hulk giant man and beast are on the
scene most of the monsters are easy
pickings for the experienced superheroes
but Groot
puts up a bit more of a fight using his
roots to tangle up the thing and Hulk
but ultimately he's defeated by the team
of heroes and locked away although
obviously
for good agent of shield groots road to
redemption begins in 2005 s Nick Fury's
Howling Commandos miniseries but not
before the Arbour alien gets in a few
more licks under the leadership of
SHIELD agent clay Quartermaine the
Howling Commandos are a band of monsters
charged with hunting and capturing other
monsters and that includes group
Quartermaine and his team find Groot
hiding in a forest but the shield agents
plasterer group with sonic weapons
eventually capturing the titanic' tree
groots prison term is short-lived the
evil wizard Merlin sends an army of
goblins and other supernatural creatures
to attack the Howling Commandos base
Quartermaine opens the prison doors
freeing Groot and the other prisoners
causing a stampede that turns the tide
of the battle while the other monsters
flee Groot stays behind and helps the
team traveling on groots back the
Howling Commandos take the fight to
Merlin's stronghold and put the wizard
in his place and give Groot the
redemption that he desperately craves we
are Groot is the big twist the Groot who
joined the guardians of the galaxy might
not be the same one who terrorized earth
for 50 years since apparently everyone
on Planet X is named Groot
that theory is confirmed in guardians of
the galaxy number 14 which explores
groots origins before he left home Groot
lived peacefully on Planet X where a
group of squirrel like maintenance
mammals keep the forests in tip-top
shape one day some young saplings decide
to harass one of the school critters and
that's when the trouble starts another
young Groot presumably al Groot
intervened saving the little creatures
life as the maintenance mammals thanked
the heroic Groot for his interference
the other groots attack again and that's
when good guy brute as them into pieces
as punishment the ruling groots exiling
from planet x depending on how you look
at it Groot is either a bully a murderer
or both so in a way it doesn't matter if
he's the same Groot who debuted back in
1960 he's damaged goods no matter what
Groot destroyer of worlds technically
this isn't something terrible that Groot
has done it's something that he'll do in
about 30 years according to an elaborate
virtual reality simulation Rocket
Raccoon number 9 flashes forward to
about 2046 and we see that Groot has
returned to his original colossal size
and plows through New York
he also ploughs through he's the
longtime sparring partner the Hulk who
becomes a snack for the rampaging
monster as Iron Man explains the
Avengers tried to use groots
regeneration powers to cure all diseases
but as is often the case when it comes
to comic book science the process
backfired
turning brute into a giant mindless
beast Tony Stark tracks rocket down and
tries to enlist his help but rocket is
old and bitter and wants nothing to do
with any of Earth's heroes meanwhile the
rampaging Groot tears shield Helicarrier
in half sending Steve Rogers plummeting
to his death iron men soon follows
smushed under groots wooden fist rocket
finally arrived
half-drunk and transforms his ship into
a giant mech to fight groot but it's no
match for brutes raw strength he tears
both the robot and his furry friend to
pieces still it's not all in vain
rocket sacrifice snaps groot back to his
senses and transforms the monster into a
giant life-giving tree while rocket goes
down in history as one of the world's
most important heroes that's a really
bad sign
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our youtube channel
plus check out all these cool stuff we
know you'll love to
[Music]